you know i don't know exactly how the
woke people got in charge
here in so many places it's partially
because they're so loud i think there's
five or ten percent of people here who
really believe in that stuff
and they've gotten very good i think it
came from the universities you look at
our big tech companies
the culture of google is really modeled
off of stanford because it's all the
phds same thing with a lot of the other
ones
and so these tech companies are
basically taking a culture from a
university that's
you know that's been broken for a few
decades and uh and these will people are
really good at punishing people who
stand up to them and trying to get them
and so it's not worth people's time to
push back and if you're just trying to
do your job
you're just you know you're just you're
just you're just doing you're just doing
what you can
and see these people get to be in charge
it's really bad
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report locals week
joining me today is an entrepreneur and
investor and policymaker at the cicero
institute joe lonsdale welcome to the
reuben report
thanks dave good to be on joe i've
wanted to have you on for
for quite some time because you're
involved in in about a billion things
that
sort of ancillarily are all about the
things that i talk about on this show
from tech to politics free speech
education all of it um but first let's
start with those
those two words that i mentioned up
front uh entrepreneur and investor i
feel like when you say that to people
people think oh you were just kind of
like born that way how does somebody
become an entrepreneur and investor i
suspect a lot of my audience would like
to have those two tags
well you know there's a lot of different
types of this but for me
it's about you see things and they work
a certain way and you're frustrated and
you want to fix them so i think
i think i think having a vision of how
the world should work that's not how
it's working right now
that'll lead one to be an entrepreneur
because that's basically the only way to
do things to evolve the economy
so how'd you get started for the guy out
there watching this right now going okay
i got a regular job but i've got an idea
or i'm passionate about something like
how did it work for you well you know
technology is a really big part of what
you need to be a great entrepreneur
these days you don't have to be a
technologist but it's a big advantage to
learn technology
learn computer science and you know i i
was i grew up in the bay area i was very
lucky i was born in silicon valley
had a bunch of friends who were great
technologists they taught me from a
young age
i went to stanford computer science i
met a lot of great technologists when i
was there i saw a lot of the smartest
people were going to work at paypal
and you know at the time it was 2000
what was this paypal thing
and it was a company that had been
started by there's one company started
by peter thiel and one company started
by elon musk
and they merged and they made paypal so
of course peter brought his smartest
friends elon brought his smartest
friends
and i said well i want to work there and
they actually rejected me the first time
but i tried again and they let me in
and i learned a lot from them so i think
what you want is follow the best
technologists learn technology
and go study under people who know what
they're doing and that's probably a good
way to get started
so as a guy that was involved in those
sort of magic years
of silicon valley and and of big tech
and all that
when you look back on it does it feel
like a dream sort of like seeing sort of
the way
big tech has moved and how the landscape
has changed and how people generally
talk about big tech
versus probably what you were seeing
when it was being born does it all just
feel very weird because it's not that
long ago as you said
yeah i remember being at a dinner with
peter he was the first investor in
facebook and mark
mark was there i know the facebook
founders really well of course from this
background
i remember being jealous because the
other really important people at the
table
were treating mark is more important
than me and i said pounce here's going
to be a really big company
why is this device why do you think
facebook's necessarily going to be
bigger so
obviously i was wrong that uh that we
were going to be nearly as big as
facebook
i went public last week for 22 billion
so we didn't do horribly but but uh
it's all it's like but you know we're
not worth five you know wherever mark's
worth you know trillion dollars
but uh but no it is interesting having
known a lot of these characters and
they're very ardent very hard working
people
i don't think any of us knew how big
these companies were going to get though
i like how you just poo pooh-poohed 22
billion 22. yeah yeah 22 billion last
week
we'll get to that by the way someone
who's like crushed it and done way
better than you right
at least that's been in my experience
it's kind of funny i was
actually going to get there a little bit
later but let's just jump to it do the
numbers like when you say something like
that okay so so palantir went to ipo 22
billion dollars like it
the numbers start to seem crazy do they
seem crazy
even to you guys that are in in it
because i think to the average person
it's like
you can't fathom what one billion
dollars i i don't think most people can
fathom
you know what 10 million dollars is
you know it's yeah i i think i guess in
some ways i'm lucky
that it took so long because if as
things take time over the years you kind
of adjust to it
i think if it were to all of a sudden
fall on your lap after after a couple of
years it would probably be extremely
unhealthy i
actually there's there's things i worked
on with peter you know at the fund where
we had a hedge fund that kind of blew
blew up one year where i would have
gotten this giant bonus that you know as
a 25 year old and i didn't and looking
back it's probably good that i didn't
because if you just get a bunch of money
all at once it's hard to it's hard to
adjust to it
if you build these things over time it
like that you kind of learn how to
manage it you learn
you know the money is not like a bunch
of gold coins if you ask me as a kid i
would have thought it was like scrooge
mcduck and there's like a tower and
there's gold coins in it and then we're
gonna you know and it's like that's what
money is because you don't dive into
your tower with the big dollar sign now
you know it's actually not
maybe maybe at some point we should
figure that out but it's actually my
experience
no any of my friends had breakfast with
peter thiel yesterday he made more on
palantir of course than paypal was worth
you know
and uh and uh you know when it was sold
to ebay of course uh when he first did
it
but but you know that these people the
money represents these missions
and these causes and and the money is
ownership and something you've built so
it becomes
much more about it's the money you say
sure it's worth some
large amount on paper but it's much more
about the ability to get things done in
the world ability to influence things so
at some point it's not money you're
going to spend for yourself it's one
you're going to use
to achieve stuff and to build stuff yeah
do you think that's the fundamental
disconnect
when we talk about money and when
there's a certain level of resentment
when these companies go to ipo or when
the
when they see people getting you know
these huge payouts or something that
they they don't really understand like
the work that it took and the way these
things change
industries and everything else like
there's a disconnect between what's
actually
going on with a lot of these companies
and and what
sort of the media portrays it all as
yeah i mean well of course it's a
massive amount of work and of course a
lot of people wouldn't take bets on
these things wouldn't invest in them
wouldn't do them
if there wasn't an economy where you
could earn lots of money but i think the
biggest disconnect
is is that there's really two options
with these resources we're creating
is is once the resources have been
created either you're going to have a
bunch of committees and bureaucrats in
charge without money
or you're going to have these really
hard working people who know how to
build things in the world like elon musk
and peter thiel
and all sorts of other people with
different views who you know who've
created this money
using it as they see fit and i i you
know it's amazing most of the money in
the world now is run by committees you
know most of the money is taken by
pension funds
sovereign wealth funds like 98 of the
money in the world is controlled by
these big
slow boring things like insurance
companies and those guys don't usually
do anything that's that interesting
whereas there's this small number of
people who've created wealth
and and even that lot that's like the
last free wealth in the world and people
want to take that and give it to the
committees too it's like what are you
what are you thinking i mean don't you
want people who know how to build taking
this and using it for something
so you're giving me the perfect segue to
i think something that
that a lot of people wonder about how is
it that a place like silicon valley that
has so much of the spirit that you're
talking about
these people who want to change the
world who want to invent
and innovate and the rest of it how is
it that
the social justice thing which is so
counter to that in many ways
how did it infect almost everything to
the point that everybody's leaving san
francisco right now
yeah it's uh it's it's a huge problem in
the culture of silicon valley
um there this this has been this has
been the case you know for a very long
time is when you're when you're very
successful
and wealthy and philanthropic i think i
think a lot of people
will have some some level of guilt about
their success and then and then
and the guilt doesn't have to be
rational it's just like you're guilty
there's people who are poor in the world
and you have success
and so like the cultural norm i think
becomes
becomes very very careful about being
proud of your success of
showing off any pride any of that at all
and in the deep in the default becomes
you know it becomes taken over by the
left at some point
you know i don't know exactly how the
woke people got in charge here in so
many places it's partially because
they're so loud i think there's five or
ten percent of people here who really
believe in that stuff
and they've gotten very good i think it
came from the universities you look at
our big tech companies
the culture of google is really modeled
off of stanford because it's all the
phds same thing with a lot of the other
ones
and so these tech companies are
basically taking a culture from a
university that's
you know that's been broken for a few
decades and uh and these will people
are really good at punishing people who
stand up to them and trying to get them
and so it's not worth people's time to
push back and if you're just trying to
do your job
you're just you know you're just you're
just you're just doing you're just doing
what you can
and uh these people get to be in charge
it's really bad so how do you how do you
run companies then
and make sure that they don't get
infected by these ideas
i mean it's really important who you
hire first of all like a lot of our
companies you got to be really careful
who you let into your company you do not
want a social justice activist
who's going to be stirring things up
like i loved what the
ceo of coinbase brian armstrong put out
the other day that a lot of us shared
and uh our company is not about all
these other things it's about our
mission
and you know we have there's other
places you can go if you want to focus
on other missions this is our mission
uh so a lot of my companies we spend a
you know decent amount of time let's be
really careful who we let in
and and i have to have to teach ceos
this is your job you
don't come to me a year from now and say
this is so horrible these people are so
distracting they're pushing us to do all
these stupid
things that would have been your fault
for not figuring out and for hiring them
so this is something a lot of people are
learning about right now
it's funny i always find it interesting
how it deviates from the core mission
always like if every single commercial
you watch these days
it's a company but it's not about their
product it's about what they're you know
what quote unquote good they're doing
the only company that i know may like
major company
that's not doing it is t-mobile and they
they're all their commercials are about
their product and
i'm always like oh there there's i know
what they're selling it's incredible
does it go real it's a real company and
you know i think there is a role there
is a role
for consumer brands to stand for values
that people believe in i think
in a free market people could choose to
put their money towards brands that go
towards things they believe in and if it
was purely reflecting the desires of the
market
i think that's interesting i think the
problem is a lot of these big companies
is the marketing departments are
conquered by people with these extremely
well views that do not reflect their
customers and that becomes a really
weird disconnect that i'm hoping the
market will solve for that eventually by
pushing back on some of these things
yeah all right so let's back up to that
poo poo moment when you pooh-poohed the
22 billion so
uh so okay so palantir went to ipo
uh about it's about 10 days ago by the
time we post this um
can you just i've had peter on as you
know uh but but can you just explain
what palantir is i feel like palantir
gets a lot of really bizarre press
and people have no concept of what it
actually is it's because it is a pretty
complicated thing to explain though the
best way i like to look at it
is we're taking things that used to be
done by i.t services so we started off
in the defense world in the intelligence
world and the us government spends 40
billion dollars a year
gathering data and then they spend you
know a similar amount of money paying
i.t service professionals to try to
build systems to let the analysts see
the data
let them share it etc and it's a mess
they always their projects go
way over budget they waste billions of
dollars as you'd expect on these things
they're paying people to do things the
same way they did in the 1980s 1990s and
so looking at this after 9 11 we said
you know wait a second here the
technology in silicon valley has gotten
way ahead of everything dc is doing and
that's actually that was that was a sad
thing for us to realize because when
you're a computer scientist
you look at the nsa in the 1970s and
they were way ahead of everyone else by
far so it used to be the us government
was way ahead it's not anymore no
question
and and so we said how can we build a
platform
that out of the box replaced the need
for the tens of billions of spend so our
platform is an information
environment where you could take in data
from tons of places a process that's
it's very very expensive and hard to do
and takes a very long time and then
secure it and make sure only people who
are allowed to can see it
and allow people to build tools on top
of it to to collaborate so for example
we help
we help you know intelligence agencies
around the world collaborate we help
aerospace companies and their suppliers
collaborate with data so it basically
helps you use all the data you're
you're allowed to you're allowed to use
and only people who are supposed to see
things see them so it's just it's a hard
it problem so for for more libertarian
minded guys like you and peter does that
cause like a little bit of a
of an ethical dilemma you're working
with the government
well the whole the whole way there's two
different things there first of all
what was happening before we built
pounds here was they were building
systems to see things with basically
very little safe cars because anybody
who needed to
you imagine like jack bauer in the show
24 and there's a terrorist he's just
going to go in the database and take the
freaking data he needs
because otherwise someone's going to die
right and so people are like a lot of
people are like exclusive liberties
we're just going to take whatever we can
and so as civil libertarians we said no
we're going to build pounds here it's
going to give them more powerful access
but it's also going to be able to make
audit trails we're going to know exactly
who did what
and we're going to enforce the rules and
whatever the rules are we're going to
enforce them we don't make the rules
president obama makes the rules
president bush made rules we're going to
enforce whatever the ruling congress
does we're going to force those rules
and so so first of all first of all it
was actually palliative is like the most
awesome privacy engine in the world
because
we really enforce it if you use pounds
here it's very hard for you to get away
with anything you're not supposed to do
so that was something we were really
heartened by the second one's an
interesting question i've built a lot of
things now
in gov tech uh you know i think for me
it's part of being a realist
you think you asked about being a
libertarian you know cato is the most
famous libertarian in the roman republic
and what cato would do is he he wouldn't
compromise at all so he was really
admired for being uncompromising and
constantly
you know fighting for what was right but
because he wouldn't compromise he
wouldn't work with pompeii
pompey went over to caesar they
eventually lost the republic because he
was so stubborn
he couldn't get things done and
therefore he lost the entire thing and
the entire thing was gone
so as much as i admire cato and i have a
lot of kato in me as i've grown up
i'm a realist and so i want to fight for
my values as well as possible but if the
government's going to be doing something
like let's actually help it reflect our
values of a free society as much as
possible let's help it not waste
billions let's help it protect civil
liberties
let's help it actually get the
terrorists because in the worst of all
worlds is that the government
is doing all these things and it's
viciously incompetent i think that's
probably really bad for everyone
yeah you're speaking my language so can
you explain to me then as someone that
has worked with the us government why
are there so many government websites
that are so ridiculously old and broken
i mean i pay
i always use the example and i and you
as a california guy
i pay my california state taxes on a
website that literally looks like it's
prodigy
from 1999. why is that there's no dave
there's no accountability and there's no
incentives
and the people who win these government
contracts are working through these
really byzantine procurement rules that
favor the incumbents in favor of the
people that have paid for massive
amounts of lobbying they've been doing
it the same way since 1987 or whenever
they started building
these things probably 97 for that
website you know but and so so what we
need in government is we need
to completely change how pyramid
procurement works
and we need to have accountability and
have metrics and and all the same things
you do in a business and my business is
if we have a website there's
there's certain rules for measuring how
well it's doing and measuring the
feedback you probably need mps scores
right and nps scores when you get
you know how much people like it and how
much they'd recommend it to friends
there's things like this the government
should have to do and
and the prob the biggest problem is
government has special interests
everywhere especially government unions
that refuse to let them be held
accountable so until we can hold our
governments accountable
um it's just going to keep being broken
yeah all right i want to shift a little
bit because as you know
we're doing locals week here and when i
when i created locals and when i had the
idea of locals and i brought in some of
the team for locals
we had to raise a little bit of dough
and i started asking around
and a lot of people your name just kept
popping up people just kept saying this
sounds like joe alonso you got to talk
to joe lonsdale
i don't even remember i'm not even
totally sure how we got connected but i
do
but i we we jumped on a zoom or on a
skype
and in the first conversation within
five minutes you were like yeah i want
to throw you guys some money and good
luck and and you've helped guide us with
this thing
when when someone approaches you um this
doesn't have to be about local
specifically
but generally when people approach you
with ideas like this like what goes
through the checklist in your mind of
like oh this is something i want to fund
or i see something here or
you know i'm going to write a massive
check for this one or a little bit for
this one like what is the whole process
like
sure well so so you know 8vc is my
venture fund we run a multi-billion
dollar venture capital firm
there's 40 people nine partners and at
epc we have different themes we're
focused on
and the big question there is what's
possible now if that was not possible
five years ago
that's a big question and we will look
for really top technology cultures and
tech talent and help nurture and build
those
then we look for them working on these
problems that are newly possible because
again the job of venture capitals evolve
the economy
so you have a lot of things in that vein
i also do a much smaller amount of
personal investing when something is
just really important to me
ideologically or for the world even if
it doesn't fit exactly into my
vc bucket uh i'd love to support things
i think are very important for the world
like what you guys are doing
yeah do you sense that that the sort of
small internet or the bottom up internet
is the future that we're going to move
away from these big tech
platforms and do things a little bit
more like what we're doing with locals
where people will kind of create their
own communities and
kind of figure out how to network up so
it's really just flipping the whole
thing upside down
i i would i would i would love that to
be the case i think i think in some
cases that will be that will be what
happens
i get the one of the big challenges
that's unusual right now is
in the old days when you think of a
monopoly you think of something that
gets to be somewhat decadent
and guess nc starts to decline and right
now there is
at least for today an advantage that the
big companies have is they keep
attracting the very very very top talent
so as much as i think they're doing
things that are morally and ethically
wrong
a big challenge we're going to face to
bring that vision you mentioned which
which is very possible
possibly good vision is how do we how do
we compete for top talent because
it's a very unusual circumstance they
may be monopolies but they are they are
just hiring all
the top talent which is very impressive
to still watch yeah and it's like you
you've got some dough it's not like you
can't compete
but they've got they've got even more of
those money machines
google has like this but i mean people
people think pounds are being worth 22
billion dollars or something google's
money machine i think shoots off like
three or four billion of free cash flow
a quarter
right it's just it's just ridiculous how
much money these guys have yeah do you
know what they're actually making money
on at this point i've i've heard a bunch
of people talk about this that it's like
what products do they have that are
actually
making money versus yeah well one of my
companies actually is
funds like a few percent of their
revenue for google and facebook
it's the it's the number two to amazon
called wish and we just advertise
and we do like dollar store stuff online
it's like having a walmart online
and so there's things like that we're
selling stuff to consumers and consumers
are
are finding it but there's basically
everything everything you sell
these guys make money on especially
google anything anything you might
search for anything you might
want to figure out who google has gotten
to be very very good at monetizing
yeah what do you think generally about
the subscription verse ad
model these days is that changing a
little bit now that that people have
sort of woken up to some of this stuff
yeah i think i think i think you said i
think for the bottom up world you're
going to start seeing a lot more
subscription model
and is how things work i think that is
how media should work my favorite media
i'm a subscriber
to whether it's whether it's like i mean
the information
is this technology you know it's it's
kind of a little bit it's like slightly
well but it's like better than the other
ones in fact
in fact it's hard to have to find
everything you get and but it's like
it's just you know i think a lot of
stuff you guys you guys features is
there's a lot of people on there who are
definitely worth following subscribing
to
so i just yeah i think things are
shifting back to subscription because
it's a healthier thing
but but we're gonna see hopefully get
more in that direction yeah
so let's talk a little bit about sort of
your your political life so first off
what for people that have no idea what
what cicero is can you just explain what
they are first then we'll talk about
your
involvement a little bit yeah sure so
you know it kind of grew out of a lot of
my
my other activity where you'd learn
about different industries and you'd say
wow this is really broken i wonder why
this part of healthcare doesn't work
this much better way they would be like
five times as efficient
and sometimes you'll find oh well they
need a system we need to do something as
an entrepreneur and we'll build
companies
uh but a lot of times you say you know
it's not because no one's built a
company
it's because the policy is just wrong
it's like the policy here
is causing health care to be three times
as expensive the policy here is causing
housing to be twice as expensive as it
should be in this area
and so and the more i look at politics
and the more i get afraid of socialists
you know coming and convincing our kids
to be socialists
the more i've realized wow every area of
our society that's broken
it tends to be broken because of big
government and because the best ideas
are not allowed to compete and win what
you want in society the reason free
society works is if someone has a better
idea
that idea wins out over time this is a
better way for us to do probation and
parole
because less people will go back to jail
you want a way for that idea to win
and i think a lot of people don't
understand this they think that you just
publish like this is a better way to run
a prison and then other people just
adopt it and then society will move
forward
and it turns out that's not how society
works it's a false model of society the
correct model of society
is you have to have a competition of
ideas you have to have accountability
you have to have something that makes
the bad ideas lose
and the good ideas win and so cicero is
is helping put forward laws
it's helping figure out where we can
take these best ideas and identify them
and create systems where the best ideas
will win in these areas is the hardest
part of that just the messaging where i
think
most people unfortunately they just see
oh something's screwed up
like it just needs more money like
that's just like the the one level
thought you know i think it's a really
hard thing to teach people to think in
terms of systems most people are not
systems thinkers
i think i think what a systems thing you
know a good leader
might say this is a good program i'm
going to give it money whereas a great
leader would say how do we redesign the
system
so that the good things are winning and
the bad things are going away and so the
redesign the system problem is
is not is not how people think and that
you know the market is a system the
market's with the greatest systems there
is
and the more we can reflect things the
you know better systems the better but
you're right
people don't understand it very well
right so like can you give me a couple
examples like the type of things like
let's talk about healthcare like
what can we do to clear up this
healthcare mess
oh gosh give me your presidential debate
platform
there's there's there's so there's so
many things we're pushing there's a
group called pbms three of the fortune
20 companies or pbms pharmacy benefit
manufacturers they're the guys
who to tell pharmacists what drugs they
could sell and make them available to
them they're kind of the middlemen
on drugs in america and they do all
these things where they gag everyone
and so one thing we stopped them from
doing which was good it was till we
finally passed in the senate two years
ago i was very
very involved putting this forward is
they used to say okay pharmacist if
there's two generic drug options
and one even if one is you know 20 times
cheaper than the other you're
if the doctor prescribes the more
expensive one you're not allowed to tell
him or the patient
uh you can tell her or the patient about
the cheaper ones totally crazy right so
you're just like and you know
i think there's still so we got rid of
that that's illegal now
what was the logic behind that that's
just purely because they're in the
pocket of this
cartel is their cartel power they like
being able to make tons of more money
using their cartel yeah they say we're
not going to give you these other drugs
only we have access to
because we're this cartel and it's
really hard regulatory to compete with
us
unless you unless you don't tell these
things but here's another thing they do
they don't let people tell the prices
they're paying so a pharmacist
would love to be able to say hey other
pbm
upstart here's what i'm paying on these
uh you know
can you give me a better deal and that's
illegal you're not allowed prices are a
trade secret according to these cartels
in america
and there's lots of parts of healthcare
like this where all the prices are trade
secrets and they won't tell you ahead of
time
because that stops competition from
coming in on them and so you know
insurance companies would love to be
able to go to other providers and say
you know these people are
charging us this much over here can we
can we pay can we pay a lot less but
there's all these
there's all these like think gag orders
where you can't do that it's against the
rules and so
you know in my view in order for a free
market to work better you want
competition
and therefore you want to ban these gag
orders and so gag orders are something
only cartels will want
and it's amazing dave you go to congress
i talk to senators and they say you know
i've had all these people visit me from
the pharma lobby and they've explained
to me
that if this thing was transparent
everyone would collude and prices will
go up
and i'm like oh i'm like okay guys it's
like it's like okay guys you're these
are paying billions of dollars to
convince you
that it's your vision of this right and
and then if it was transparent it would
make the markets not function as well
and it's like this is senators on both
sides man this is i i love working on
issues i obviously believe in freedom
and believe in free markets
but there are people bought off in this
country on both sides by these lobbies
who
who are not putting in the pro-market
solutions and so we're working hard on
it i
i'm optimistic we're going to win but in
every one of these areas
uh there's there's like there's stuff
like this that just drives me crazy it's
kind of hilarious you go into a
congressman's office they tell you that
if they
take this secrecy awa and then everyone
can actually negotiate prices will go
up there there's they definitely missed
something in in economics but
we had conversations like this with
people on both parties and who are and
they're people at both prices who are on
the good guys side too you know but it's
just
it's right it drives me crazy do you
find the the partisan gridlock do you
find it
is it 50 50 is one side worse than the
other is one side a little more
i mean i think generally speaking people
on the right are a little more open to
free market stuff but is it pretty close
people underwater are more open to free
market stuff but i mean the freedom
caucus for example will i admire a lot
of them a lot of them are cato's where
the thing i said earlier
where they're so extreme that they won't
even compromise a little bit it's
interesting the bush white house
i have a lot of admiration for for dick
cheney and a lot of issues but dick
cheney's
was so stubborn as a kid on this issue
that he didn't want to require
transparency because he said the market
should be able to figure it out
we shouldn't have to require
transparency and and but in all these
other healthcare analysts including
myself
say you know it's pretty obvious you do
need transparency here because that's
the only way it's going to work and
there's so many
little mini monopolies and whatnot that
you need to it makes it more like a
market and more like a free society with
more competition
and he was afraid to impose transparency
because he thought that was telling the
market what to do so it's interesting
you have people on the far right who are
pretty intrinsic
sometimes about some of these things
yeah what else should we be thinking of
as like the big issues related to to
health care like okay prescription drug
prices like
like what are the other types of things
that you know another really big one
the biggest the way you look for in
these spaces you look for where all the
contribution margin is what contribution
margin is in business
it's you know it is of course it's it's
it's how much money businesses are
actually making
uh before you know on the services
they're providing and
and the biggest area of contribution
margin is health providers health
providers are hospitals basically or
things like hospitals
and it's really it's really egregious
how this works and it's tough because no
one wants to be against their local
hospital it sounds like the thing you
should give money to and support
but a lot of hospitals like medicare and
medicaid literally will pay two to three
times as much
for the exact same service to a hospital
versus a clinic because the hospitals
have so much power and they've set
things up that way where they're getting
and they say oh
we have to get paid more because we have
more expenses and i'm thinking wait a
second in a market you don't want to
have to pay three times as much for the
same exact document or even a worse
outcome
and it's really interesting if you if
you map it out there's all these health
systems that have bought up
lots of things in an area to give
themselves more pricing power because if
they buy the one nearby
then you can't have competition you
can't you can't actually have an
insurance company says well we're only
going to work with this reasonable one
not this other one
and uh and it's really bad and here's
the thing that's really crazy a lot of
these health systems are non-profits
and so if you say oh it's a non-profit
you know that means it must be a good
good guy for the world you can't do
anything and so the ftc the federal
trade commission
is not allowed to look at nonprofits
right now so you have all these things
have gotten on profit
have bought up massive amounts of an
area and then can jack up the prices a
lot and people running on profit are
making
huge amounts of money even though it's
officially a non-profit and uh and it's
a big problem so
one of the one of the big things is is
antitrust
and letting the ftc do antitrust against
nonprofits as well
and and really what it's about is about
creating competition it's about putting
markets
back into place here yeah how do you
decide when the government can get
involved there the libertarian side of
you
well i guess that's what you're saying
about being a realist as opposed to
you realize i i you know i mean i mean
another big
libertarian thing here is make it easier
to start competitors right make it
easier to start health clinics to
compete
the problem is if you have monopoly
power it's just so dominant in that area
and you're allowed to tell the health
insurance like if you work with this guy
we won't work with you and everything's
secret and you can't say what we're
charging you
it becomes they basically become these
things that's the kill competition and
that's
that's that's fundamentally un-american
america works better if you can have
competition in these areas and there's
there's lots of ways there's lots of
like you know
good academic work i'm measuring what a
monopoly is or not and it's just it's
comical to me that we're going after the
tech monopolies to start right now
when we have a much bigger problem in
this country of the healthcare law
please on all sorts of local levels
and if you know if the ftc should use
the academic literature
that's been written by both sides the
last 70 years the the conservative view
of antitrust
is in my view is correct the bork the
borkian view basically that bork created
as one of the great legal scholars
which is you look at the impact on
consumer and the prices and and
you could very clearly see places where
we're spending two three four times as
much for certain services
it's very clearly a monopoly if there's
any view where the
ftc is supposed to do something to me
that should be it and so
so and again if you want to say that you
don't need government at all
sure if you got rid of all health care
regulations i mean it really easy to
compete
maybe this problem would solve itself
but we're not going to get rid of all
those things and so therefore let's
let's let's
find some way to get competition and
make make it healthy right so what
what would the right system look like
like
would it be just a lot of individual
companies that are sort of corralled by
the government to have to play
fairly like what what does it actually
work you want to be as open as possible
right i mean you want to be as open as
possible you want new types of
competition to be able to come in
you want people to be able to choose
their own health plans one of the things
government messed up as you know is in
the 1940s in world war ii
we made it so you couldn't pay people
more but you could give them benefits
and and we made like healthcare but a
tax-free benefit so it created this
system in our country where we started
expecting to get things
from of course people want to pay people
more so they just gave them better and
better health plans and so everyone got
used to having a health plan
from their company tax-free and not
choosing it themselves and so got rid of
a lot of choice there
uh and people don't even know some h
some random hr person who's probably
super awoke is the one you know choosing
your health care plan for you
for for a lot of americans that's not
how things should work
and and so like what it what it should
be is it should be that that
it should be that people choose their
own health plans so so you know ovic roy
has something senator braun i think put
out yesterday which is a really great
new health plan
and what it is is basically it's uh it's
going to cover everyone
it's not going to cover rich people it's
means tested so anyone at 55 or under
you're not going to get medicare if
you're rich
going forward and and it's they cover
everyone using the market which is that
everyone gets to choose their own
private insurance company and any new
startups have the people have to choose
the health insurance themselves
and then in the meantime we're going to
have antitrust we're going to have
transparency and we're gonna like push
back on these really sketchy tactics
people use on ip
on drugs where they've had vip for
decades and they're still keeping it
expensive
so there's a combination of like using
markets using private insurance
and you know and and means testing and
this is like this is a compromise again
and covering everyone
but basically basically everything's
private but the bottom gets covered by
but you know by the government and
that combination would save money and
work yeah i think we need a compromise
like this to keep our health system free
yeah have you been tracking uh what uh
jared kushner is doing with oscar is
that related to any of the types of
things
i guess that's that's that's jared's
brother josh oh sorry josh joshua
yeah jared jared as jared is very busy
and peace
jared's got other things going on yeah
yeah josh josh i'm a
i am a fan of the kushner kushner
brothers and i've i've brought a lot of
my friends in the valley say oh that
jared must guys be horrible and i
i show him some stuff he's doing or
connect them to him and they end up
liking him in person he's actually a
pretty smart guy
in my opinion uh josh has done a great
job with oscar
you know there's a lot of ways oscar
uses data uses telemedicine no one had
done before
uh it was fascinating you know we we had
a bunch of clinics on the platform of
course you know this is a health
insurance company it's growing quickly
and i i put 100 million dollars into it
so we have like one of my one of my 20
or 30 big investments
and and there and there was like this
pediatrician group and they said how
come we're not on your platform
and we told them well listen you guys
spend three times as much on tests as
any of the other pediatricians
in this area and they said oh wow we
didn't know that no one ever told us
that before and we said
we said wow what a strange space like
these people have no idea how much money
they're spending it's just
it's such a broken area that none of the
insurance companies had even told them
that
that they were doing things
unnecessarily and so i just yeah so
oscar's done a lot to kind of push
health insurance to use data and to be a
better
to be you know to be a better force so
i'm very bullish on it yeah
i know uh your your one of your other
sort of main places of interest is
criminal justice reform i feel like this
is one
where almost everyone agrees something
should be done and and there can be
something that's sort of bipartisan and
in many ways trump seems to be trying to
do things that i thought lefties were
fighting for for
for a long time how can we fix this
clearly broken
trump and jared have done a good job on
this there's a lot of people on the
right who are suspicious of some of this
and i i don't
i don't blame them uh a lot of a lot of
criminal justice reform that's being
pitched like getting rid of bail or
you know you make us you you rest these
guys then get out you have to arrest
them again and they get out you have to
arrest them again there's a lot of
ridiculous criminal justice reform i'm
not for any of that
uh the part that i'm for is is again how
can you fix the systems that are failing
people so
you know a few systems that are failing
people one of them is probation and
parole
there's literally amazing probation
parole officers who really spend time
you know deploying the tactics to lower
recidivism to help these people
and like they see their job as they're
serving these people and they want to
keep them out of prison
and they want to help them succeed in
life and they want to be easy on them uh
you know easy on when they can hard on
them when it's helpful for them
and and there's other probation parole
officers who are absolutely horrible and
they're just
nasty to these people and they and they
you know they get a job it's too far
away and they have time to see the
parole officers they throw them back in
prison what you know
what what whatever it is they're just
like make things so tough on them
and so the question is how can you have
incentives for probation and parole
you know i'm not usually a fan of
california we're talking about this
earlier i know you're still staying here
in the state but one thing they did
really well 11 years ago
is a bipartisan bill where they they
changed the incentives for county
probation offices
to actually be able to get to keep some
of the money if they didn't send as many
people back to prison
as long as the crime rate didn't go up
and it worked extremely well saved the
state a billion dollars over the last 11
years
and we're actually in montana did
something similar so we're taking those
successes
and we're teaching people okay let's do
this for california parole now too let's
actually have incentives where the
parole officers actually care about
doing their jobs
because what happened as soon as you
passed that law is all these offices
started studying and sharing notes what
works for recidivism how do we do
how we do this better how do we care
about this only everyone's getting
measured you know bob
uh you've sent everyone back to prison
in the last seven years that's really
hurting our numbers
maybe you should care about you know not
not just standing back maybe you should
try actually work with them and try to
help them and here's some tactics and
techniques we found work you know
and so it's it's amazing having
accountability in these areas what that
could do
yeah what about education what's go
what's going on here it seems to me
choice choice choice choice choice and
yet that seems to be a scary thing to
people
yeah well i'm generally obviously a fan
of choice that's the thing we're talking
about in every area is competition and
choice but
there's different levels of education uh
you know there's
all of them are really important we
gotta get to our get these kids when
they're young and make sure they're not
programmed by marxists as little kids
that's that's that's important but
in terms of the incentives we think we
can work on incentives are easier to do
with
the latter part of education because you
can measure the results and one of my
favorite programs to really go after
right now there's something called pell
grants
and their pell grants were created for
good reasons they're really well meaning
we're trying to help people from you
know bad serious economic backgrounds or
lower socioeconomic backgrounds succeed
in life and send them to college
and the problem is there's no
accountability at all so we spend 30
billion dollars a year
on pell grants in this country and the
results are just completely different so
there's there's some
there's some schools that do a great job
and for the exact same type of kids
they'll have twice the salary coming out
of those schools
as others and you know you know when you
think about university
it's not just about getting a high
salary like i think we can all agree on
that university
is about it is about being a great
citizen you know to live in a free
republic
it is about you know moral action those
are both legit things for universities
to care about
but the third thing definitely is
learning how to get a skills to get a
job learning how to actually succeed in
life
and we're going to spend 30 billion
dollars a year maybe part of the pell
grant program should care
that they're getting skills or not when
they're going to these schools and
because the results are literally two to
one
the question is okay these really really
crappy schools but they probably all
become protesters or god knows what
they're going to do afterwards because
they don't have any jobs
in the average salaries you know 21 000
or whatever from them maybe we shouldn't
be giving as many pell grants to go to
those schools and these great ones where
people are making more and twice as much
as that
maybe they should be getting more pell
grants right so the question is how do
you put incentives into these programs
to take into account the data and right
right now we don't do that at all on our
government
probably should yeah do you think we
could just let a whole bunch of these
public schools just fail
and just that that would just clear out
the brush that i mean that that
if you do this for title four or two
that would count so title four is the
loans we give our hundred billion
dollars on loans we give out a year
and it's pretty obvious that pell grants
plus title four are propping up like
this bottom 30 percent
of these schools that are just
absolutely horrid in these schools
probably care a lot more about whatever
like crazy ethnic studies
things they're doing whatever racism
they're teaching our kids and they
actually care about anything helpful for
america so
yes you know japan did this recently
they closed a bunch of their like
of their like kind of weaker kind of
wackier liberal arts
departments in their bottom schools and
it was a big outcry but i thought it was
pretty awesome the japanese just like
kind of did it
uh yeah yeah i think we could do that
too now now that of course would be more
something the right would do in the left
would scream bloody murder so
rather than do that let's just start
with some incentives where we kind of
maybe maybe trim the bottom with
incentives that are nonpartisan that'd
be my my hope is there's a non-partisan
solution here that we can push forward
first so so
even if you could do some of that stuff
and you change what you're doing with
grants and some of the handouts and some
of that kind of stuff
do you think that the the academic layer
of it has just been so corroded
and and calcified and corrupted that it
almost won't matter
whether whether you know they pull some
of the string purses and that kind of
thing
you know i think people respond to money
there's going to be some academics there
that are going to be wacky and useless
anyway
but there's going to be some of these
boards that react and say oh wow rather
than talking our entire board meeting
about how woke we are and how to be more
awoke
maybe we should look at this data that
says we're not teaching any useful
skills
maybe we should see what these five
schools nearby that are doing great or
teaching
maybe we should like add some of those
in for these poor kids that are coming
here to try to build a life
rather than just brainwashing them and
you're right not every one of them is
going to say that a lot of them are just
going to be
completely dysfunctional and that's
that's why markets are such an important
thing markets
markets get rid of bad ideas right so if
these things are not working
then the school is going to shrink
because there's gonna be some
accountability you know and so so that
that that is it
i think some can adapt and i think some
probably should go away
yeah so as a as a pretty
forward-thinking guy
in a forward-thinking industry um
linking this back to the political thing
i think a lot of people
feel like we're sort of at the end of
something like my feeling right now with
our political gridlock is just we're
just at the end
of this thing the fact that uh whether
you like either one of them or not that
a 77 year old is running against a 74
year old one of them's
been in politics for 47 years one of
them's you know been in in private
industry forever
good bad and different it doesn't matter
that we're just sort of at the end of
this cycle
what do you think we need from our
politicians
after this well first off do you think
there is an after this do you think we
get out of this thing or does it
reconstitute itself in some other evil
form four years from now
you know it seems very likely that we
that that we potentially get if
you if you get some kind of biden find a
victory you get some kind of like
this the whole thing goes on a little
bit longer and
and you know what we need is we need
competent outsiders
breaking into government and shaking it
up we need people who understand systems
what that really means is you need you
need
you need some non-will computer
scientists frankly you need some
engineers who know how to run things
and and that's something as much as i'm
disgusted by the ccp and by things china
does one huge advantage china has in
certain areas
is that the majority of the people in
charge there have engineering
backgrounds
majority people in charge of our country
right now have are lawyers
and and i'm not sure that's the right
answer for the future but we need people
who are optimistic
who can paint a vision of how this
country can be much better i mean this
is what drives me crazy dave
it's obvious how we have enough we have
enough ability to generate wealth and
prosperity for everyone
we have a golden age basically and we
have we have diseases being cured
my friend jennifer won the nobel prize
this morning for for crispr right
there's
there's just amazing stuff going on in
this country an amazing potential
and we need people who could take the
optimism take the values of a free
society
and show positive some ways of solving
our problems and i i think we can get
that but it's going to be a different
set of leaders than we have right now
lonsdale that's a pretty solid closing
statement
although although wait a minute i feel
like i have to ask you one more now you
know with locals we haven't even gone
into series a yet but when i get to this
thing to ipo
what kind of party do i throw at the 22
billion like what do you do what do you
do that what do you do that night
i had about uh you know it's funny i had
about 30 friends over who built it with
me but when
of the of the 50 people i invited 20 of
them had already moved out of california
so that's why you know i gotta leave
next week but it was
it was uh it's it's a good success you
know it's it's not pouncey was never as
much
this is honestly the case never as much
about the money we we helped them target
and eliminate over 8 000 bad guys
including the most famous ones you know
in the last decade and uh and we
helped help serve our country and we've
helped save a huge amount of money so
i'm really proud of the company
awesome well joe lonzell i enjoyed
talking to you and i'm enjoying working
with you and i'm going to see if i can
add a couple more zeroes
to your situation let me see what i can
do over here
i'm bullish on you thanks dave all right
thanks okay
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell